the final guest video in this run is
from Ali and Micah a neuroscientist and
a clinical therapist who run neuro
transmissions their video has giant
magnets 3d printing and the star wars
action figure ally mica it's all yours
we're here at the Keck Center at UC San
Diego and this is a functional magnetic
resonance imager or an fMRI well
functional but not functioning this is
actually a dummy scanner that's used for
educational and training purposes an
actual fMRI machine houses a three Tesla
magnet that's more than 60,000 times
more powerful than the Earth's magnetic
field and over three thousand times more
powerful than your average fridge magnet
if we were anywhere near the real deal
well we would put our camera and our
equipment at serious risk but why on
earth would anyone possibly need a
magnet so powerful well some of the
researchers here at UCSD are using fMRI
to study the human brain in ways that
thirty years ago just weren't even
possible I'm Maggie I'm a fourth year
graduate student at UC San Diego my name
is Stephanie Nelly I'm a sixth year PhD
student in John senses lab we study
mostly selective attention and
expectation and other cognitive factors
and how they influence visual processing
in humans my research is about really
basic visual perception how do we make
sense of the world around us how do we
choose out of the plethora of things
that are constantly kind of a costing
our visual system how does your brain
kind of make sense of the massive amount
of information constantly bombarding it
fMRI itself was developed not very long
ago it's a very new technique as far as
human research goes and it was developed
in the 90s I believe actually in Bell
Labs from Riya is a particular specialty
of MRI i'm called functional MRI so what
that does is basically instead of
measuring the difference between a
particular tissues you're actually
optimizing to detect the difference
between oxygenated versus deoxygenated
blood and a person's brain for a long
time it was impossible to look at the
brain up close without cracking open
someone's skull and even if you got a
brain from someone who's passed on
that's not all that useful for
understanding how it works when Leonardo
da Vinci dissected the humor
brain in the 16th century it was with
the intention of finding the seat of the
human soul
spoiler alert he didn't unsurprisingly
the functions of different brain areas
were essentially a mystery well after
the Scientific Revolution but fMRI
changed all of that by giving scientists
the ability to see the brain working in
real time track activities in different
brain regions and greed your mind no
unfortunately not for a scientist an
fMRI machine cannot read the mind I can
tell you basically where blood is being
transported to in the brain so which
parts of the brain are active an fMRI
scan can tell you when someone is doing
some cognitive tasks what kind of
patterns of brain activity you see so
which areas are active what information
of those areas representing for instance
if you have someone look at different
images and you measure MRI while they do
that then later if you have that same
person come in and you say okay think
about something now I can based on that
information I can guess what you were
thinking about I could probably say
you're looking to the left by looking at
your neural activity or I could say
you're looking at a horizontal line by
looking at your neural activity however
am I gonna be able to tell what you're
daydreaming about or who you're in love
with or something like that no I don't
think that's gonna happen in in my
lifetime but you know set it on camera
so we'll be able to it might not quite
make sense how a magnet does all of this
so let's break down the process step by
step let's say that Ray here has been
having some neurologically linked
problems and a doctor refers her for an
fMRI Oliver force powers are messing
with her head
oh no kylo Ren keeps appearing in my
mind I can't stop thinking about his
torso oh the technicians place her on
the table
give her some ear plugs and stabilize
her head so she can't move it at all if
the head moves during the skin the
images will come out fuzzy next the
table slides into this large donut
shaped section which houses the ultra
powerful magnet the strong magnetic
field of this magnet then actually turns
the hydrogen atoms in our blood wait
what yeah the human body has a lot of
hydrogen atoms because well we're mostly
made up of h2o that's why the magnetic
field from the fMRI interacts with the
protons in the hydrogen atoms and makes
those protons essentially point in the
same direction that's right your
molecules are magnetic
hence the magnetic resonance part of
magnetic resonance imaging once raised
in position she'll hear a series of very
loud clangs and beeps
[Music]
but these sounds aren't just the hottest
new beat they actually serve a purpose
every clang you hear is a radio wave
pulse being fired off this radio wave
disrupts the uniform direction of the
protons and pushes them in slightly
different directions here's the cool
part as the protons move back into
realignment they release their very own
small radio signal and those signals are
then detected by the fMRI machines radio
receiver which starts taking snapshots
of cross sections of your brain which
you here as the beeping sound after some
complicated computation which shows up
on the computer screen as a series of
images that show both the anatomy of
your brain and highlighted areas where
there's more blood flow pretty cool
right yeah so fMRI doesn't actually
measure your brain activity it can't
detect your individual neurons firing as
cool as that would be fMRI machines
actually detect what's called the bold
signal so the bold signal stands for
blood oxygen level dependent signal and
it's basically an index of how much
oxygen aided hemoglobin is in a person's
blood at a particular point in their
brain neurons themselves don't keep a
high you know store of glucose hanging
around so that they can do their job and
so the blood vessels through these
things called astrocytes actually help
supply neurons with the glucose and
oxygen that they need to do their
signaling when you have a neural
activity that happens in your brain a
bunch of blood will rush to that area
and it turns out that oxygenated and
deoxygenated at hemoglobin in your blood
have different magnetic properties so
deoxygenated hemoglobin will kind of
disrupt the magnetic field more than
oxygenated hemoglobin will and it'll
actually cause a decrease in the signal
so when you look at an fMRI image the
higher the signal you have the more
oxygen is in your blood at that point
and so you actually can measure that the
bold signal after these neural events
occur that basically tells you how much
energy was consumed at that location now
it's not perfect like it can't detect
changes instantaneously or tell you
exactly what kinds of signals are
being sent but even with its limitations
it lets us better understand which brain
regions do what using fMRI scientists
have been able to identify a hundred and
eighty distinct brain regions better
understanding the roles of different
brain regions means that doctors can use
that information to help treat and
support patients with neurological
disorders or brain injuries fMRI
technology is cool but both of us wanted
more we wanted to get into the Machine
and see what our own brains look like
Maggie and staff asked me to participate
in a pilot research study looking at how
humans distinguish between faces and I
jumped at the chance to help out I
didn't participate in the study but I
was able to get a structural skin it
doesn't measure blood flow but it does
give you a high-resolution image of your
brain's anatomy it was a strange
experience being inside it felt like
being in a plastic coffin I can see why
some people get classroom phobic and
participating in this study was harder
than I expected while the task I was
doing was easy it was hard to stay
focused on doing the same thing over and
over for almost two hours
but it was also really cool to see the
results and yet we could not pass up on
the opportunity of a lifetime I mean
sure it's cool to see your brain on a
screen but imagine holding it in your
hands what does my own unique brain
really look like well as it turns out
we're able to find out thanks to modern
software we're able to take the 2d
slices of our brains and compose them
into a 3d render and print them out cue
the time-lapse
[Music]
look at that beautiful brain I really
liked how the rainbow filament turned
out it turned out really cool I know and
I really liked my glow-in-the-dark
print it's like super bright the grooves
are much wider and yours not quite as
tightly patent or as mine is like super
tightly folded it's cool that you can
see the inside too like the hippocampus
and all these different brain regions
obviously I knew that my brain wasn't
perfectly symmetrical no one's brain is
but you can really see like very obvious
differences it's really interesting to
see like oh that's the like that's my
brains shape every time someone comes
over to our house a bit did you see my
brain let me show you my shame I mean
it's incredible that we have the
technology to track the activity of a
live human brain fMRI has pushed
neuroscience to new heights and has
given us a glimpse into the seat of
human consciousness and only somewhat
less incredible is the fact that we can
use those same images to build 3d models
so we can create a life-sized version of
our own brains how funny that just a
chunk of squishy cells this big I can
come up with such incredible tools to
help us better understand our minds and
ourselves huge thanks to Maggie and
Steph and the Saran celeb for their
expertise and to UCSD for giving us
access to their scanner and thanks to
Tom for giving nerds like us the chance
to share our brainy love maybe we'll see
you later maybe until next time we're
neuro transmissions over and out thank
you folks go subscribe to neuro
transmissions I would recommend starting
with Micah's video on training a cat to
high-five or Ally's video on how
marijuana affects your brain and that's
it I'm back next week and I will see you
then